[Music]
she more like you work on you now that
she's five she's a Gemini so she's a
little bit of both
she definitely has Kanye's outgoing
personality and will say whatever is on
her mind no matter what it is or who it
might offend and then she's also really
common sweet like me Kim Kardashian
opening up to et about daughter
Northwest at her k'kaw beauty pop-up
shop in Los Angeles how would you keep
her grounded to get like a chore chart
just that she has to make her bed you
know there's so many things that she has
to do if she wants to get something so
she doesn't really get a whole lot of
stuff like you would think and she's got
to be nice to her brother see how's that
going yeah it goes up and down
she definitely has been better since the
little baby is here but st. and
Chicago's relationship is so sweet but I
don't I don't know what's gonna top that
Kim also dished on sister Khloe's big
move back to the west coast from
Cleveland where her boyfriend Tristan
Thompson plays basketball for the
Cavaliers the two welcomed their first
child daughter true to the world in
April shortly after her little sister
Kylie Jenner delivered her little girl
stormy how excited are you that Chloe is
now back in LA that's so nice to have
her back oh I'm so excited they came
back on Sunday and I just piled the kids
in the car and took them over to go meet
their cousin true and it was a love fest
I mean it's so much fun I feel like
stormy and Chicago have so many photo
shoots together and we just text the
pictures to Chloe
of them like sitting on the couch and
we're like where you at true we're
waiting for you and so now that she
could be in the mid
it's gonna be so much fun
[Music]